GOOD AFTERNOON AND
WELCOME TO THE JULY TWENTY
SEVENTH TWENTY TWENTY HEARING
OF THE ASSEMBLY ELECTIONS AND
REDISTRICTING COMMITTEE. THAT
THAT THAT THAT THAT- WE'RE
GOING TO BEGIN AS A SUB
COMMITTEE IF MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE ARE MONITORING THIS
HEARING FROM THEIR OFFICES
PLEASE COME TO ROOM FOUR THIRTY
SEVEN. SO THAT WE CAN ESTABLISH
A QUORUM. TO THE CONTINUED STAY
AT HOME ORDER. WE'RE PRACTICING
PHYSICAL DISTANCING HERE IN THE
HEARING ROOM AND THROUGHOUT THE
CAPITOL BUILDING SO WE ARE ONLY
ABLE TO HAVE A LIMITED NUMBER
OF PEOPLE WATCH AND PARTICIPATE
IN THE HEARING IN PERSON. WE
ARE ALSO REQUIRING THAT MASKS
TO BE WORN. AND PHYSICAL
DISTANCING BE MAINTAINED BY ALL
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC.
TESTIFYING WEATHER HERE IN THE
ROOM OR AT A VIDEO CONFERENCING
SITE. IF YOU DO NOT HAVE A MASK
WE CAN PROVIDE ONE FOR YOU WE
HAVE A FEW DIFFERENT OPTIONS
FOR WHEN HIS TESTIMONY TODAY
TODAY AND ROOM FOR THIRTY SEVEN
OF THE STATE CAPITOL. WE CAN
ONLY ACCOMMODATE A MINIMAL
CONTINGENT OF STAFF AND A
LIMITED NUMBER OF THE PUBLIC.
AND MEDIA SO WE CAN MAINTAIN
SIX FEET OF SPACE AND- THEY'RE
ALSO STRICT PHYSICAL DISTANCING
PROTOCOLS FOR THE PUBLIC TO
ENTER AND LEAVE THE CAPITAL.
AND FOR THOSE HERE IN THE ROOM.
IF ANY MEMBER. LET'S JUST BREAK
FOR A SECOND AND ESTABLISH A CO.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. BERMAN HERE. BERMAN
HERE GALLAGHER GALLAGHER HERE
CALDERON LOW LOW HERE MAYES
MAYES HERE MULLIN WEBERWE HAVE
A QUORUM RATE SO WE HAVE A
QUORUM AND THERE ARE ALSO A
STRICT PHYSICAL DISTANCING
PROTOCOLS FOR THE PUBLIC TO
ENTER AND LEAVE THE CAPITAL IN
FOR THOSE HERE IN THE ROOM. IF
ANY MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC IN THE
ROOM WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY ON
THE BILL PLEASE RAISE YOUR HAND
AND I'LL ASK YOU TO APPROACH
THE MICROPHONE AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. I WOULD ASK
THE PUBLIC NOT TOUCH THE
MICROPHONE YOU CAN EXIT THE
HEARING ROOM ONCE YOU ARE DONE
TESTIFYING OR RETURN TO YOUR
SEAT. PLEASE BE SURE TO OBSERVE
PHYSICAL DISTANCING UPON
LEAVING THE CAPITOL INCLUDING
LIMITING ELEVATOR USED TO ONE
PERSON AT A TIME. IN ADDITION
TO BEING ABLE TO TESTIFY FROM
INSIDE THE HEARING ROOM. THEIR
REMOTE TESTIMONY STATIONS.
LOCATED ON THE CAPITOL GROUNDS
AND IN OTHER LOCATIONS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. WHERE
WITNESSES CAN TESTIFY. THOSE
WITNESSES WILL APPEAR ON THE
SCREEN SO MEMBERS CAN WATCH
THEIR TESTIMONY LIVE FROM
OUTSIDE OF THE HEARING ROOM AND
ALSO ASK THEM QUESTIONS. WILL
ALSO BE USING A MODERATED
TELEPHONE SERVICE THROUGH WHICH
ANY WITNESS CAN TESTIFY ON A
BILL. THE CALL IN NUMBER FOR
THIS HEARING IS EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN. AGAIN THAT WAS
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO.
EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN. IN THE
ACCESS CODE IS ONE THREE ONE
FIVE FOUR. THREE SEVEN. AGAIN
THAT'S ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR
THREE SEVEN. YOU CAN ALSO FIND
THIS NUMBER ON THE ASSEMBLY
ELECTIONS AND REDISTRICTING
COMMITTEE WBSITE AS WELL AS ON
YOUR TV OR COMPUTER SCREEN. IF
YOU ARE CALLING IN. PLEASE PLAN
TO DIAL IN AS THE AUTHOR OF THE
BILL YOU'RE TESTIFYING ON IT IS
BEGINNING THEIR BILL
PRESENTATION. THE OPERATOR WILL
GIVE YOU INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO
BE PLACED IN Q.BASED ON
WHETHER YOU SUPPORT OR OPPOSE
THE BILL. IF YOU ARE CALLING IN
PLEASE ELIMINATE ALL BACKGROUND
NOISE THIS INCLUDES MEETING
YOUR LIVESTREAM BROADCAST AND
YOUR SMART DEVICES. TO REDUCE
THE SOUND DISTORTION. PLEASE
ALSO BE ADVISED THAT IF YOUR
PRIMARY WITNESS PROVIDING
TESTIMONY FOR AGAINST THE BILL
YOU WILL REMAIN ON A LIVE LINE
AND WILL NEED TO MEET YOURSELF
UNTIL YOU ARE CALLED ON TO
SPEAK. IF YOU'RE HAVING ANY
PROBLEMS WITH THE MODERATED
PHONE SERVICE YOU CAN CALL THE
COMMITTEE AT NINE ONE SIX.
THREE ONE NINE. TWO ZERO NINE
FOUR AND MY STAFF WILL BE THERE
TO TRY TO HELP. I ALSO WANT TO
KNOW THAT WE ARE ACCEPTING
WRITTEN TESTIMONY THROUGH THE
POSITION LETTER PORTAL ON THE
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE. THANK YOU
FOR BEING WITH US AS WE
IMPLEMENT METHODS TO CONTINUE
TO SERVE THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA WILL ALSO BE MINDFUL
AND RESPECTFUL. OF THE PUBLIC
HEALTH CONCERNS WE ALL FACE.
BEFORE WE MOVE THE BILLS ON THE
COMMITTEE'S AGENDA OF A FEW
ADDITIONAL HOUSEKEEPING
ANNOUNCEMENTS TO MAKE. FIRST I
HAVE A LETTER FROM SENATOR
STERN REQUESTING THAT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MULLIN. BE PERMITTED TO
PRESENT SB SEVEN THIRTY NINE.
ON HIS BEHALF. AS ONLY MILLER
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MULLIN THANK YOU
FOR YOUR ASSISTANCE IN
PRESENTING THAT BILL FOR THE
COMMITTEE TODAY. SECOND I HAVE
A LETTER FROM SENATOR UMBERG
REQUESTING THAT I BE PERMITTED
TO RICK PRESENT SB FOUR TWENTY
THREE. AND SB NINE SEVENTY ON
HIS BEHALF SO I WILL BE
PRESENTING THOSE BILLS AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. THIRD THE
COMMITTEE HAS BEEN REQUESTED BY
THE SPEAKER'S OFFICE TO PASS AS
BEFORE TWENTY THREE DIRECTLY TO
THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR. SO THE
MOTION ON THAT BILL TODAY WILL
BE TO PASS THE BILL TO THE
FLOOR. FOURTH THE COMMITTEE'S
RULES GENERALLY PROVIDE FOR
BILLS TO BE HEARD IN AUTHOR
SIGN IN ORDER. IN A LOT OF THE
LOGISTICAL CHALLENGES WITH
CONDUCTING COMMITTEE HEARINGS
IN A MANNER THAT IS CONSISTENT
WITH THE NEED FOR PHYSICAL
DISTANCING. HOWEVER ALL
COMMITTEES HAVE BEEN ASKED. TO
HEAR BILLS IN FILE ORDER.
ACCORDINGLY WILL BE HEARING
BILLS AND FILE ORDER TODAY.
THIS CHANGE IN OUR USUAL
PROCEDURE IS CONSISTENT WITH
THE COMMITTEE'S RULES WHICH
PERMIT BILLS TO BE TAKEN UP IN
ANOTHER ORDER IF THE CHAIR FIND
TO BE MORE. EXPEDIENT WE HAVE A
QUORUM. FINALLY WE HAVE ONE
BILL ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
ITEM NUMBER FOUR SB SIX EIGHTY
FOUR BY SUNDER HERTZBERG DOES
ANYBODY DOES ANY MEMBER WISH TO
REMOVE AN ITEM FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. SEEING AND HEARING
NONE DO WE HAVE A MOTION ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. WE HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THIS IS ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
BERMAN HI BERMAN HI GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER I CALDERON LOW LOW HI
MAYES MAYES AYE MULLIN MULLIN I
WEBER WEBER HI THAT'S SIX ZERO.
THAT BILL IS OUT ON A SIX ZERO
VOTE WILL KEEP THE ROLE OF AN
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS- WITH ALL
THOSE ANNOUNCEMENTS OUT OF THE
WAY WE WILL NOW MOVE ON TO THE
BILLS ON THE COMMITTEE'S AGENDA
THE FIRST BILL TO BE PRESENT AS
NUMBER SB FIFTY EIGHT BY THE
ESTEEMED SENATOR ALLEN BEFORE
WE BEGIN IF THEY'RE MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC WERE INTERESTED IN
SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF ONE
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL PLEASE
CALL AND NOW AS A REMINDER THE
PUBLIC CALL IN NUMBER FOR THIS
HEARING IS EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN.
SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE FIVE
SEVEN AND THE ACCESS CODE IS.
ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR THREE
SEVEN SENATOR ALLEN THANK YOU
FOR JOINING US TODAY YOU MAY
PRESENT. YOUR BILL. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU MEMBERS
I WANT TO FIRST COMMEND THE
CHAIR FOR. HER OAKLEY- READING
ALL OF THAT PASSED HIS FOGGED
UP GLASSES AS THE GLASSES WHERE
I'VE- FOUND THAT. THE MASK
SITUATION ALL THE MORE
DIFFICULT BECAUSE THEY- THEY
REALLY MAKE IT HARD TO SEE. I
ALSO WANT TO THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR FOR YOUR FOR YOUR FOR
YOUR WILLINGNESS TO HEAR THIS
BILL- YOU KNOW I UNDERSTAND
THAT WERE ALL UNDER VERY. TIGHT
CONSTRAINTS AND- I THINK YOU
RECOGNIZE THIS BILL FOR WHAT IT
IS- A TIGHT IN A GOOD PORTENT
AND ACTUALLY URGENT. CHANGE TO
THE LAW TO. ADDRESS THE ISSUE
IN LA. THAT WE ALL CREATED FOR
THEM- AND- AND I JUST
APPRECIATE YOUR IN THE BILL. I
WANT TO START BY ACCEPTING THE
AMENDMENTS OUTLINED IN THE
ANALYSIS ADDING AN URGENCY
CLAWS AND THANK THE COMMITTEE
FOR WORKING WITH MY OFFICE ON
THE BILL- A THIS IS A THIS IS.
A TECHNICAL CLEAN UP BILL THAT
CLARIFIES THAT NO PARTY
PREFERENCE. VOTERS CAN BE
INCLUDED ON THE LA COUNTY
INDEPENDENT REDISTRICTING
COMMISSION PROPORTIONAL. TO
VOTER REGISTRATIONS IN THE
COUNTY. THE LA COUNTY NEVADA
REGISTRATION COMMISSION WAS
CREATED BY US BY THE
LEGISLATURE. IN TWENTY SIXTEEN.
IT HAD THE GOAL OF PROVIDING A
SIMILAR PUBLIC PROCESS AS WAS
PROVIDED BY THE CITIZENS REDUCE
OUR COMMISSION STATEWIDE. AND
THIS INCLUDES THE SELECTION OF
FOURTEEN COMMISSIONERS THAT ARE
REFLECTIVE OF THE POLITICAL
PARTY PREFERENCES OF THE
COUNTY. BUT MP PEAS ARE NOT
CONSIDERED A POLITICAL PARTY.
ALTHOUGH THEY MAKE UP ONE POINT
FOUR MILLION VOTERS OR OVER A
QUARTER OF THE REGISTERED
VOTERS IN LA COUNTY. SO THIS
BILL- WILL FOR PHIL THE SPIRIT.
OF THE ORIGINAL LAW- THAT THEY
AND BASICALLY MAKE IT SO THAT
WERE VERY CLEAR THAT ANTI P.
VOTERS CAN BE INCLUDED AS
COMMISSION MEMBERS BY CLEARLY
STATING. THAT NO PARTY
PREFERENCE CAN BE INCLUDED ON
THE COMMISSION PROPORTIONAL TO
VOTER REGISTRATIONS. IN THE
COUNTY. CURRENT LAW REQUIRES
THE COMMISSION BE CREATED BY
DECEMBER THIRTY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY SO EMERGENCY CLAUSE. IS
NEEDED TO ENSURE THIS
CLARIFICATION IS CODIFIED WITH
ENOUGH TIME FOR THE COUNTY TO
INCLUDE NO PARTY PREFERENCE
VOTERS IN THE COMMISSION.
SELECTION PROCESS AS YOU KNOW
NOW WE HAVE THE CENSUS THIS
YEAR AND- SO WILL BE GOING
THROUGH THE PROCESS OF CREATING
THE DISTRICT LINES IN LA COUNTY
JUST AS WE WILL BE. DOING
STATEWIDE. THIS IS THAT- BILL
THAT THAT IS CRITICAL TO ENSURE
THAT THE INDEPENDENT DISTRICT
COMMISSION REPRESENTS THE
POLITICAL DIVERSITY. OF LA
COUNTY VOTERS AND ON THE PHONE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. IS BRIAN STAGGER ON
BEHALF OF LA COUNTY AND I. WANT
TO TURN OVER TO BRIAN. RIGHT
PRIME PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU ALLEN GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE BUT AT THIS PRICE
YOU'RE GONNA REPRESENT THE
CATAPULT THEM TO LOOK AT THE
ONE FIFTY IT IS IMPORTANT BILL
FOR THE CAT LOS ANGELES AND
WHAT IT MEANT LOS ANGELES
COUNTY DISTRICT IN COMMISSION
LAW REQUIRED THAT THAT
PROPORTIONAL REPRESENTATION ON
THE REDISTRICTING COMMISSION
INCLUDE THE CATEGORY OF VOTERS
IN THE COUNTY WHO ARE
REGISTERED AS MALE PARTY. IT IT
REQUIRES THAT TO MISSION AT THE
WINTER. YES OF COURSE WAS
POSSIBLE TO THE COUNTY. VOTERS
REGISTERED WITH ITS POLITICAL
PARTY USING THE MOST RECENT
STATEWIDE ELECTION DATA.
HOWEVER I'VE BEEN AROUND SAID
NO PARTY PREFERENCE VOTERS ARE
NOT CONSIDERED A POLITICAL
PARTY. OCTOBER 26% OF OFFENCES
CAN VOTERS. I WOULD BE QUICK TO
ONE POINT FOUR MILLION VOTERS
ARE REGISTERED WITHOUT THE
PARTY. AT THE ONE FIFTY EIGHT
THE CLERK BY VOTERS REGISTERED
AT OUR PARTY PREFERENCE CAN BE
INCLUDED ON THE COMMISSION.
PROPORTIONAL TO VOTER
REGISTRATIONS IN THIS COUNTY.
THE CLARIFICATION IS NECESSARY
TO ENSURE THE FOR A ELIGIBLE
FOR CONSIDERATION ON THE
COMMISSION. AND WHAT HELP
PREVENT A THIRD PARTY CHALLENGE
TO THE LAW. AND. I'M JORDAN FOR
THE QUESTIONS THAT YOU MAY HAVE.
THANK YOU STARR. ARE THERE ANY
OF THIS WITNESSES IN. OF THIS
BILL. WE'RE HERE IN THE ROOM IF
SO PLEASE RAISE YOUR HAND.
SEEING NONE THROUGH FOGGY
GLASSES LET'S NOW GO TO OUR
REMOTE TESTIMONY STATIONS OTHER
ANY WITNESSES AT ONE OF THE
REMOTE TESTIMONY STATIONS TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT. OF SB ONE
FIFTY EIGHT. HEARING NONE THE
PHONE LINES ARE NOW OPEN FOR
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OF SB ONE FIFTY EIGHT.
MODERATOR DO WE HAVE ANYBODY ON
THE LINE WHO WISHES TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF SB ONE FIFTY EIGHT.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS
ONE BEEN FERAL NOW. AGAIN TO
SHOW SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE
THAN THEIR OWN NOW. WE HAVE NO
ONE NINE Q. AT THE MOMENT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MODERATOR.
TO DON'T BEAR WITH ME. SO WITH
MEN. WE WILL NOW MOVE ON TO ANY
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL THE
COMMITTEE DID NOT RECEIVE ANY
LETTERS OF OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL SO WE DO NOT HAVE A
PRIMARY WITNESS IN OPPOSITION
IF IS THERE ANYONE HERE IN THE
COMMITTEE ROOM WHO WISHES TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO SB. ONE
EIGHTY THREE. ACTUALLY IT HAS
THE ONE FIFTY EIGHT THANK YOU.
SEEING NONE. LET'S NOW GO TO A
REMOTE TESTIMONY STATIONS ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES AT ONE OF
THE REMOTE TESTIMONY STATIONS
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO SB
ONE FIFTY EIGHT. HEARING NONE.
THE PHONE LINES ARE NOW OPEN
FOR WHEN THIS IS IN OPPOSITION
TO SB ONE FIFTY EIGHT MODERATOR
DO WE HAVE ANYBODY ON THE LINE
WHO WISHES TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO SB ONE FIFTY
EIGHT. THANK YOU A LIKE COUPLE
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO.
AGAIN TO OPPOSE PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN THEIR OWN NOW. WE
DON'T HAVE ANYONE IN Q. AT THE
MOMENT GREAT THANK YOU MADAM
MODERATOR- THANK YOU SENATOR
ALLEN- WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
THE SARGSYAN ME SKIP QUESTIONS
YES. BRING IT BRING IT TO THE
COMMITTEE. IT'S NOT A QUESTION
IS A COMMON THANK YOU FOR DOING
THIS AS THE LEGISLATURE'S US
THE WHOLE- NO PARTY PREFERENCE-
A MEMBER- IN I THINK IT IS
IMPORTANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THERE IS- IMPROPER- THE GROUPS
THAT SERVING ON THESE
COMMISSIONS THE FACT THAT THE
LANGUAGE IS MESSED UP ON
RICARDO. ABOUT THIS I'M SORRY-
THAT AT THE CENTER LARA- AT THE
TIME- HAVE HAD HAD DONE THIS I
THINK IT'S GREAT THAT YOU'RE
DOING THIS AT THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR THEIR BRAINS FOR ONE THING
THAT I'VE LEARNED SINCE I AM-
NOW- A NINE- IS THERE'S LOTS OF
THINGS IN THE LAW THAT NEED TO
BE CLARIFIED SO THERE'S GONNA
BE SOME TIME TO GO TO WORK ON
SOME OF THIS. FOR NEXT YEAR BUT
IS ONE OF THINK YOU. FROM HIS
FORD. GOMEZ SURE GO THERE. YES
THANK YOU SENATOR AND I THINK
YOU HIGHLIGHT IN YOUR OPENING
ONE OF THE ISSUES HERE IS THAT
WE CREATED THIS PROBLEM- FOR
THE LOCALS WHICH IS ANOTHER
REASON WHY I DID NOT SUPPORT
THE ORIGINAL LEGISLATION
BECAUSE THIS SHOULD BE
SOMETHING THAT THE LOCALS- COME
UP WITH THEY DRIVE HOW THEY
WANT TO DO THE REDISTRICTING-
AND YOU KNOW THERE'S ONE OF THE
PITFALLS OF A WE- SORT OF
LEGISLATING FROM ON HIGH- HOW
REDISTRICTING SHOULD. GO IN AND
ONE COUNTY THAT WE RUN INTO
THESE PROBLEMS THAT I WILL BE
SUPPORTING THIS IS A CLEAN UP
YOU KNOW AND TO KNOW ENSURE
THAT BUT I THINK IT ALSO
UNDERSCORES WHY IT REALLY. YOU
KNOW IF YOU WANT TO HAVE
FAIRNESS IT SHOULD REALLY BE
JUST AS WE'VE DONE STATEWIDE
WITH OUR REDISTRICTING. FIVE
REPUBLICANS FIVE FIVE
DEMOCRATS- ONE AND PP I THINK
IS WHAT IT IS RIGHT NOW. WE CAN
DO SIMILARLY AT LEAST PROVIDE
THAT SAME. EQUALITY YOU KNOW
REPRESENTATION- IF WE'RE GOING
TO DO IF WE'RE GONNA BE WAYNE
INTO THIS WE SHOULD TRY TO KEEP
IT AS- YOU KNOW EVEN AS
POSSIBLE- A IS HOW I WOULD HOW
I WOULD PUT IT BUT- I'M NOT SO
SURE THAT WE SHOULD BE WAY IN
INTO IT- AT ALL AND EVEN THE
COURT. WHEN THIS WHEN THIS
PARTICULAR REDISTRICTING SCHEME
WAS CHALLENGED- HAS SAID HEY WE
DON'T KNOW THIS RATIONAL
JUSTIFICATION IS GONNA LAST BE
ON THE NEXT REDISTRICTING.
CYCLE ON LOS ANGELES SO I GUESS
SAYS SOMETHING FOR. THE
CITIZENS AND REPRESENTATIVES OF
LOS ANGELES COUNTY TO FIGURE
OUT IN DUE TIME. THANK YOU WHAT
THE BILL MISTER ICE HERE I HAVE
A MOTION AND HAVE A SECOND. ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COLLEAGUES.
SEEING NONE NOW BRING IT BACK
TO THE CENTER WOULD YOU LIKE IT
WAS YEAH NOT A YOU TO THE
COMMITTEE I APPRECIATE THE
COMMENTS I MEAN IN THE END OF
THE DAY YOU'VE ALL PRODUCTS
BIGGER ISSUES- YEAH. THAT ARE
VALID THAT DID THIS THIS HAS TO
DO WITH MAKING SURE WE MAKE AT
LEAST THIS CURRENT SITUATION
RIGHT AS A AS AS IT AS IT
RELATES TO THE IMPLEMENTATION
OF. OF NOW COMMISSIONER LARA'S
AND BILL FROM TWENTY SIXTEEN
SO- I APPRECIATE EVERYONE'S
UNDERSTANDING OF THAT GOAL HERE
AND CERTAINLY HAPPY TO TALK
WITH FOLKS ABOUT FOR THEIR WORK
IN THIS AREA BUT TIME. FOR THE
PURPOSE OF THIS BILL CERTAINLY
RESPECT FASTER I'VE A- GREAT-
IN AS CENTER OUT MENTIONED AND
P. P. VOTERS MAKE UP MORE THAN
ONE QUARTER OF ALL REGISTERED
VOTERS IN LA COUNTY. SO BY
MAKING IT CLEAR THAT THEY ARE
ELIGIBLE TO SERVE ON THE LA
COUNTY REGISTER COMMISSION THIS
BILL WILL HELP ENSURE. THAT THE
COMMISSION REFLECTS THE
COUNTIES DIVERSITY. I'M
RECOMMENDING AND I VOTE- MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL ABOUT.
THE MOTION IS DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO ADD AN URGENCY
BECAUSE BERMAN HI. BERMAN I.
GALLAGHER GALLAGHER I CALDERON
BECAUSE I LOW LO I MAYES MAYES
AYE MULLIN. MULLIN I WEBER
WEBER I. SEVEN ZERO REMEMBERS
THANK YOU MUCH THANK YOU CENTER.
THE NEXT BILL THREE PRESENTED
OUR ITEMS NUMBER TWO AND THREE
SB FOUR TWENTY THREE AND SB
NINE SEVENTY BY CENTER AABERG.
AS I PREVIOUSLY ANNOUNCED I
WILL BE PRESENTING THOSE BILLS
ON CENTER AMBER'S BEHALF. SO I
WILL NOW- TURN THE PROVERBIAL
GAVEL OVER TO MY STAR GALLAGHER
WITHOUT ACTUALLY GOING TO
PHYSICAL GALLAGHER ALL OVER THE
ROOM- YOU READY. RIGHT. ALL
RIGHT MISTER CHAIRMAN AS YOU.
MENTIONED YOU ARE PARTY'S
PRESENTING ON BEHALF OF SENATOR
UMBERG AND I BELIEVE YOU BE
STARTING WITH SB FOUR TWENTY
THREE IS THAT CORRECT THAT
SOUNDS GOOD SIR OKAY PLEASE
PROCEED SIR THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND- COLLEAGUES. THE
NOVEMBER ELECTION. FOR THE
NOVEMBER GENERAL ELECTION IS
LESS THAN ONE HUNDRED DAYS AWAY
YEAH WE STILL DON'T KNOW WITH
CERTAINTY HOW COVERT NINETEEN
WILL BE AFFECTING US AT THAT
TIME. DID AB EIGHT SIXTY EVERY
REGISTERED VOTER IN CALIFORNIA
WILL RECEIVE A BALLOT IN THE
MAIL. PROVIDING A SAFE
ALTERNATIVE TO VOTING IN PERSON
BUT MANY CALIFORNIA VOTERS
EITHER CAN. OR WILL CHOOSE NOT
TO USE THEIR VOTE BY MAIL
BALLOT. FOR EXAMPLE MANY VOTERS
WILL NEED TO USE ACCESSIBLE
VOTING EQUIPMENT OR WHEN THE
LANGUAGE ASSISTANCE. HOMELESS
AND OTHER CALIFORNIA VOTERS.
MAY NOT RECEIVE THEIR MAIL
BALLOT. OTHERS WILL LOSE OR
DAMAGE THEIR BALLOTS AND NEED
REPLACEMENTS SOME VOTERS SIMPLY
PREFER TO PLACE THE BALLOT IN
THE BALLOT BOX THEMSELVES. IN
ADDITION ELIGIBLE PEOPLE WILL
NEED SOMEWHERE THEY CAN
REGISTER TO VOTE. UP TO AND
INCLUDING ELECTION DAY ITSELF.
SB FOUR TWENTY THREE GUARANTEES
THERE WILL BE ACCESSIBLE SECURE
AND SAFE IN PERSON
OPPORTUNITIES. FOR ALL THESE
VOTERS FOR FOUR FULL DAYS
STARTING THE SATURDAY PRIOR TO
THE ELECTION. SB FOUR TWENTY
THREE WILL ALSO REQUIRE
NUMEROUS CONVENIENT LOCATIONS
FOR VOTERS WHO WANT TO DROP OFF
THEIR BALLOTS. AS WELL AS A
STATEWIDE VOTER EDUCATION AN
AVERAGE CAMPAIGN REGARDING
PROCEDURES. KEEP IN MIND THAT
THE PROVISIONS OF THIS BILL ARE
OPTIONAL FOR THE COUNTIES. THE
COUNTY WOULD RATHER RUN THEIR
ELECTION AS THEY HAVE
PREVIOUSLY WHETHER THEY ARE
VOTERS CHOICE ACT OR
TRADITIONAL POLLING PLACE
COUNTY. THERE WILL STILL BE
FREE TO DO SO. EITHER WAY THEY
MUST STILL MAIL EVERY
REGISTERED VOTER A BALLOT. SB
FOUR TWENTY THREE WILL ENSURE
AMPLE AND EARLY IN PERSON
VOTING OPPORTUNITIES IN A
MANNER THAT IS CONSISTENT WITH
PUBLIC HEALTH GUIDANCE. AND
REQUIREMENTS WALK
SIMULTANEOUSLY RECOGNIZING THAT
COUNTIES MAY FACE COVERED
NINETEEN RELATED CHALLENGES
WHEN IT COMES TO PROVIDING
POLLING PLACES OR VOTE CENTERS.
THE WAY THEY HAVE IN PRIOR
ELECTIONS. WHETHER VCA OR NON
VCA. PARTICIPATING COUNTIES
WILL HAVE TO PROVIDE AT LEAST
ONE VOTING LOCATION FOR EVERY
TEN THOUSAND REGISTERED VOTERS.
AND ONE DROP OFF LOCATION FOR
EVERY FIFTEEN THOUSAND
REGISTERED VOTERS. COUNTIES
WISHING TO PARTICIPATE WHO MAKE
A VALID EFFORT TO COMPLY WILL
BE ABLE TO SEEK PARTIAL WAIVERS
FROM THE SECRETARY OF STATE. IF
THEY ARE UNABLE TO OBTAIN 1100%
OF THE REQUIRED VOTING SITES OR
DROP OFF LOCATIONS. AS WE HAVE
ALREADY SEEN AND SOME OTHER
STATES A MASSIVE REDUCTION IN
VOTING LOCATIONS WOULD RESULT
IN LONGER LINES. AND LARGER AND
POTENTIALLY UNSAFE GATHERINGS
ON ELECTION DAY. SB FOUR TWENTY
THREE IT WILL ENSURE. THAT WE
WILL NOT BE IN THAT WILL ENSURE
THAT THAT WILL NOT BE THE CASE
IN CALIFORNIA. AS USUAL THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSISDOES AN
OUTSTANDING JOB OF EXPLAINING
ALL OF THE BILL'S PROVISIONS
AND RELEVANT BACKGROUND
INFORMATION. SO I WILL NOT
DELVE INTO FURTHER DETAIL. AS
BEFORE TWENTY THREE SUPPORTED
BY THE SECRETARY OF STATE
POLICE WOMAN VOTERS. ASIAN
AMERICANS ADVANCING JUSTICE AS
WELL AS NUMEROUS OTHER CIVIC
ORGANIZATIONS. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. AND I
WOULD LIKE TO INVITE TIFFANY
MARK WITH THE SECRETARY OF
STATE'S OFFICE TO TESTIFY OVER
THE PHONE. AS MY PRIMARY
SUPPORT WITNESS. OKAY THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN WE WILL MOVE TO
OUR FIRST PRIMARY WITNESS IN
SUPPORT IS THAT ARE ONLY
WITNESS IN SUPPORT YEAH- YEAH.
THERE MIGHT BE PEOPLE CALL AND
BUT THAT'S THE ONLY PRIMARY
WITNESS AND AS MISS MARTHA.
PLEASE PROCEED. THANK YOU CAN
YOU ALL HEAR ME YES. OKAY GREAT
HELLO CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS EVA AND I'M
HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF
SECRETARY EIGHT OUT DHEA WE ARE
PROUD TO SUPPORT SB FOUR TWENTY
THREE WHICH WILL HELP INSURE A
MINIMUM NUMBER OF IN PERSON
VOTING OPPORTUNITIES FOR THE
NOVEMBER GENERAL ELECTION.
CONSIDERING THE COPA NINETEEN
CONDEMN ACTS SINCE THE OUT OF
THE DOWN ARE STACKED OUR STATE
HAS ACTED TO ENSURE SAFE
BOATING OPPORTUNITIES FOR ALL
ELIGIBLE VOTERS INCLUDING
SENDING EVERY REGISTERED VOTER
A BALLOT. DESERVING ELECTION IN
OTHER STATES DURING THE ENDEMIC
HAS GUIDED AND REINFORCE THE
IMPORTANCE OF EXPANDED VOTE BY
MAIL COUPLED BY AMPLE IN PERSON
VOTING OPPORTUNITIES ON IN
BEFORE ELECTION DAY. IMPORTANT
VOTING LOOKING ARE CRUCIAL
PROVIDING SERVICES INCLUDING
ACCESSIBLE MACHINES FOR VOTERS
WITH DISABILITIES LANGUAGES AT
THE SAME DAY VOTER REGISTRATION.
REPLACE ABOUT TEN MORE. THE
BILL. LOWER BILLY AND OF OUR
ELECTION. BILL WILL ENSURE IN
PERSON VOTE OPERA OR LOCATION
EVERY TEN THAT BRITISH VOTER.
RIGHT HERE IN OUR BIO
REQUIREMENT WILL ALLOW SOME
COUNTY CONTROL THE NUMBER AND
VOTING LOCATIONS AND ALL
COUNTIES. UP WILL BE ABLE TO.
THERE AB MEMBERS IT RATIO IS
NOT FEASIBLE COUNTY THANK
SUBMIT AN ALTERNATE PLAN WHICH
WILL BE EVALUATED BY THE
SECRETARY STATE. TEAM FINALLY
THE BILL WHAT THE BAND OR
CODIFIED VOTER EDUCATION AND
OUTREACH ABOUT MAIL BALLOTS
EARLY VOTING OPPORTUNITIES
SENSIBLE VOTING OPTIONS AND
WHERE AND HOW TO REMEDY ANY
VOTING RELATED PROBLEMS. FOR
THOSE REASONS WE ARE PROUD TO
SUPPORT SB FOUR TWENTY THREE.
OKAY THANK YOU MISS Mà AND NOW
WILL WE WILL GO TO OTHER
WITNESSES. AND SUPPORT. I DO WE
HAVE ANY EITHER IN THE WELL THE
FIRST WE HAVE ANY IN THE
AUDIENCE. SPEAKING IN SUPPORT.
AND ANY FROM OUR REMOTE
LOCATIONS IN SUPPORT. SEEING
NONE AND END OF ANY ON ON THE
CALL- CALLING IN IN SUPPORT.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SHOW SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE BUTTON ZERO IF YOU
ARE ALREADY AND THE KEELING YOU
KNOW YOUR NUMBER AND YOUR POLLS
PLEASE PRESS THE ONE THEN ZERO
TO REMOVE YOUR STYLE. AGAIN
THIS IS TO SHOW SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS THE ONE AND THEN ZERO.
LOOKS LIKE WE HAVE TEN PEOPLE
MAKE YOU. WELL FIRST GOTO LINE
SIXTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS THAT
COMING OUT WITH A BILL YOUR
CALIFORNIA AND STRONG SUPPORT
OF SB FOUR TWENTY THREE THANK
YOU. MAX THE AUTO LINE TWENTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS
IS THAT ALL YOU CAME WITH THE
ADVANCEMENT PROJECT CALIFORNIA
IN STRONG SUPPORT. NEXT LEVEL
TIMELINE TWENTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS CHRISTOPHER
SCIENCES RICHARD OF THE
COALITION IMMIGRANT RIGHTS YOU
STRONG SUPPORT. NEXT TO OUR
TIMELINE TO SEVEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON ERIN RODRIGUEZ THE
UNION OF CONCERNED SCIENTISTS
STRONG SUPPORT. NEXT ALL
TIMELINE FIFTEEN IN. TURN
MEMBER SALLY HOW THAT WOULD ON
WHAT THE WIDENING GROUP
REPRESENT A NEXT GEN
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT. MAX OVER
THE LINE EIGHT PM. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS ERIC TERRACE
WITH DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA AND STRONG SUPPORT.
MAX THE AUTO LINE TWENTY VERY.
GOOD AFTERNOON MABEL THING WITH
A CALIFORNIA BONTA LEARNING I'M
CALLING ON BEHALF OF CAN YOU
BASED ORGANIZATIONS AND
RICHMOND OAKLAND EVERYTHING UP
UNTIL CALL CENTER VALLEY WHICH
RIVERSIDE. NO LA AND FAILED TO
LIVE NEXT SUPPORT FOR THE
TWENTY THREE. THANK YOU.
AXOLOTL LINE FOURTEEN. HELLO ME
OF THE NEW YORK FROM THE LEAGUE
OF WOMEN VOTERS OF CALIFORNIA
I'M CALLING FROM COURT- I'VE
ALSO BEEN AUTHORIZED TO CONVEY
THE STRONG SUPPORT OF HEALTH
PRETTY COMMON CAUSE. THANK YOU.
MAX ALLOWED TO LINE TWENTY ONE.
GOOD AFTERNOON. MELISSA
PRIMARILY THE CALIFORNIA THE OF
CONSERVATION IN. MAX THE AUTO
LINE TWENTY FOUR. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS ERIN EVENTS
ON BEHALF OF NARAL PRO CHOICE
CALIFORNIA AND JOHN SUPPORT.
AND AGAIN TO SHOW SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS THE ONE THEN ZERO
ONE THEN THERE OUGHT TO SHOW
SUPPORT. YOU HAVE NO ONE ELSE
IN THE KIA. OKAY ARE MOVING
INTO OPPOSITION DO WE HAVE
PRIMARY- OPPOSITION WITNESS
TESTIMONY IF. WE RECEIVE NO
OPPOSITION LETTERS IS THAT
CORRECT YEAH OKAY SO- NO MAIN
OPPOSITION DO WE HAVE ANYONE IN
THE AUDIENCE WISHING TO. STATE
THEIR OPPOSITION. AND ANY OF
OUR REMOTE LOCATIONS. NOW AND
THEN ANYONE ON THE PHONE
WISHING TO STATE THEIR
OPPOSITION TO IT SB FOUR TWENTY
THREE. AND IF YOU WISH TO A
POLE PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
THERE- NOW. AGAIN IT TO OPPOSE
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN THERE NOW.
NOW LOOKS LIKE WE HAVE A- WE
DON'T HAVE ANYONE IN THE QUEUE
AT THE MOMENT. OKAY WILL BRING
IT BACK TO COMMITTEE. ONE THING
I JUST WANTED TO BRING UP IS
OBVIOUSLY MISTER CHAIRMAN YOU
AND I WORKED- TOGETHER ON ON
THIS ISSUE AND WE PASSED- SB
EIGHT SIX SORRY AB EIGHT SIXTY.
PROVIDES FOR AN ALL MAIL BALLOT
ELECTION. IN NOVEMBER I THINK
THAT'S THE RIGHT APPROACH TO
HELP INSURE A SAFE ELECTION
COMING FORWARD. ONE OF MY
PRINCIPAL. POLICY DISAGREEMENTS
ON ON THIS PIECE OF LEGISLATION
IS THAT IT DOESN'T FACT LIMIT
ACCESS- AND THAT UNDER VOTER
CHOICE ACT WOULD HAVE TEN DAYS
FOR PEOPLE. TO GO INTO ONE OF
THOSE- CENTERS AND EITHER GET
HELP OR TO VOTE- UNDER THIS
LEGISLATION- IF THEY OP THEY
WOULD IT'S ONLY GONNA BE THREE
DAYS. BEFORE THE ELECTION AND
ALSO POLLING PLACES- YOU KNOW
MAKE TRADITIONAL POLLING PLACES
THAT A PERSON IS USED TO GOING
TO. MAY GO AWAY- CONCERNING TO
ME AT THAT WERE YOU KNOW. WE
WANT TO PROVIDE AN OPPORTUNITY
ALSO FIRST IF THE- STAMP. IF
EVERYBODY GO ONE IN THERE FOR
FOUR DAYS ONLY. AT WHEREAS
BEANS IS DOUBT- I DO UNDERSTAND
I SUPPORT THE WAIVER PROCESS.
THAT ALLOW THE COUNTY TO FIGURE
OUT WHAT WE NEED A FACILITY OR
THIS THIS TYPE OF FACILITY THAT
WE USUALLY USE IS NOT GONNA
WORK. WE HAVE THAT ABILITY
HOWEVER DISICK BLAME WITH YOU
THAT'LL- FOR THE FOUR DAY THIS-
AND PROTECT. TO HAVE TAX. NO
OTHER THERE USED GOING TO I CAN
THAT AS BEING FOR ACTS SO I
DON'T KNOW IF YOU WANTED SPEAK
TO THOSE THOSE ISSUES BUT
THAT'S ONE OF MY BIG-
FUNDAMENTAL PROBLEMS WITH THIS
CURRENT POLICY YEAH THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND I APPRECIATE-
THE CONCERNS I DO WANT TO. JUST
KIND OF. MAKE SURE TO REMIN
FOLKS THAT THIS IS VOLUNTARY
THAT THAT OF COUNTIES WANT TO
THAT THEY CAN STICK WITH- THE
CURRENT. SYSTEM THAT THEY USE
WHETHER THERE ARE VOTERS CHOICE
ACTOR NON VOTERS FOR EXACT.
COUNTY BUT I DO APPRECIATE THE
POINT THAT YOU MAKE I MEAN I
THINK. WHAT THE AUTHOR THE
CENTER WAS TRYING TO DO WORKING
WITH ALL THE DIFFERENT GROUPS
WHETHER IT'S THE COUNTY
ELECTIONS OFFICIALS. THE
ADVOCATE GROUPS- YOU KNOW HAD
THE VOTER ADVOCACY GROUPS
EVERYBODY IS TRY TO. CREATE AS
MUCH- YOU KNOW OPPORTUNITY AS
POSSIBLE WHILE ALSO. BE
COGNIZANT OF THE CHALLENGES
THAT EXIST GET YEAH DUE TO COVE
IT IN AND DO THAT- YOU KNOW THE
DIFFICULTIES OF GETTING PEOPLE
TO VOLUNTEER AND OF FINDING A
PHYSICAL LOCATIONS THAT ARE
WILLING TO. THEY CRIED THERE'S
I THINK THE EVERYBODY. THAT WAS
JUST EASIER TO DO THAT FOR THE
FOUR DAYS- AND THAT THAT WOULD
STILL PROVIDE CON AS MUCH.
ACCESS AS AS POSSIBLE GIVEN
CODE AND THEN IT IS ALSO
COMPLEMENT TO MAILING EVERYBODY
A BALLOT- INTO THE HOPE IS THAT
YOU KNOW MUCH MORE PEOPLE WITH
THIS VOTE FROM HOME. AND FEWER
PEOPLE FEEL THE NEED TO VOTE IN
PERSON BUT I YOU KNOW I
APPRECIATE THE POINTS THAT
YOU'RE REYES- BUT BUT DO WANT
TO REITERATE THAT THIS IS
VOLUNTARY FOR COUNTIES TO. TO
OPT INTO IF THEY WANT TO. THE
IF THEY DON'T WANT TO THEN THEY
CAN DO THAT. THAT THE CURRENT
SYSTEM. OTHER COMMENTS
QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. I'M WAS APPROVED BY-
MISS WEBBER SECOND BY MISTER
CALDERON ADD WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE NO SERMON. OKAY WELL WITH
THAT- I MEAN I WILL BE OPPOSING
TODAY BECAUSE OF THAT
FUNDAMENTAL- YOU KNOW POLICY
DIFFERENCE- THERE AGAIN I THINK
NUMBER ONE WE WANT PEOPLE TO
VOTE THEIR BALLOT YEAH THAT'S
MAILED TO THEM AND I THINK
THAT'S PROBABLY THE SAFEST WAY
BUT IN THE EVENT THE PEOPLE.
YOU KNOW FOR WHATEVER REASON
NEED ASSISTANCE OTHERWISE I
THINK WE SHOULD TRYING KEEP
THIS ELECTION IS STATUS QUO AS
POSSIBLE SO THAT PEOPLE KNOW
WHERE THEY CAN GO TO VOTE AND
TO GET HELP- SO THAT'S MY
PRIMARY AND THEN. AS YOU KNOW
SECONDARILY I DON'T LIKE HOW
THIS PROCESS WENT ONE ABOUT A
MAJOR WE ARE AS YOU SAID A
HUNDRED DAYS OUT- WE THE
LEGISLATURE DID IN FACT ACT- WE
PASSED EIGHT SIXTY YEAR
LEGISLATION ON A BIPARTISAN
FASHION- YEAH THERE'S NOTHING
THAT SAYS THAT THE GOVERNOR
NEEDED TO DO AN EXECUTIVE ORDER
AHEAD OF US- AND I AND I DON'T
REALLY LIKE KIND OF ALMOST. YOU
KNOW- APPROVING OF THAT YOU
KNOW BY KIND OF COME IN BEHIND
HIM BUT WE REALLY SHOULD HAVE
ALLOWED IT SHOULD HAVE BEEN THE
LEGISLATURE THAT ENACTED THIS
THING. AND NOT THE- WAY AROUND
BUT WITH THAT YOU KNOW I'LL SO
I WILL BE OPPOSE IN TODAY ALL
RIGHT. STRICKLER TO THE
CULTURAL. THE MOTION IS TO PASS
BERMAN HI BERMAN I GALLAGHER NO
GALLAGHER NO CALDERON CALDERON
HI LOW. LOW I MAYES. MAYES NOT
VOTING MULLIN MULLIN I WEBER
WEBER I. FIVE TO ONE OKAY THE
BILL IS OUT ON A FIVE TO ONE
VOTE AND- WE NOW MOVE TO-
CENTER NUMBER X. NEXT BILL
WHICH I BELIEVE IS- SB NINE
SEVENTY. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND COLLEAGUES. CALIFORNIA HAS
TRADITIONALLY HELD ITS PRIMARY
ELECTIONS IN JUNE WITH THE ONLY
EXCEPTIONS OCCURRING BECAUSE OF
A DESIRE TO HAVE A GREATER SAY
IN THE PRESIDENTIAL. NOMINATING
PROCESS I SUPPORT KEEPING OUR
PRESS PRIME IN MORE AND THIS
BILL WILL NOT CHANGE THE
PRESIDENTIAL PRIMARIES HOWEVER
THERE IS GOOD REASON TO MOVE
ARGUMENT FOR PRIMARIES BACK TO
JUNE. EXCUSE ME SB NINE SEVENTY
JOINTLY AUTHORED BY SENATOR
UMBERG IN MYSELF. AND
PRINCIPALLY CO AUTHORED BY BOTH
THE PRO TEM IN THE SPEAKER.
WILL ENSURE THAT OUR
GUBERNATORIAL PRIMARY ELECTIONS
WILL REMAIN IN JUNE. THERE ARE
TWO MAIN REASONS TO KEEP THE
GUBERNATORIAL PRIMARY IN JUNE.
BECAUSE OF THE ONGOING EFFECTS
OF COVERT NINETEEN AT THE
CENSUS BUREAU HAS SOUGHT.
CONGRESSIONAL APPROVAL FOR
ADDITIONAL MONTHS. TO DELIVER
THE CENSUS DATA NEEDED TO
REAPPORTIONED CONGRESS. AND
EVERY JOB IN FREE DRAW
CONGRESSIONAL STATE LEGISLATIVE
AND LOCAL DISTRICTS IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. WITH SOME RELATED
THE TWO WHILE SOME RELATED
DETAILS MAY STILL BE PENDING.
WE'VE BEEN AS SHORT AS THE THAT
THE DELAY WILL BE APPROVED.
THAT DELAY WILL MAKE IT
IMPOSSIBLE FOR THE CALIFORNIA
CITIZENS REDISTRICTING
COMMISSION. THE LA AND SAN
DIEGO COUNTY REDISTRICTING
COMMISSIONS AND OTHER LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS. TO COMPLETE
THEIR WORK UNDER CURRENT LEGAL
DEADLINES. THOSE DEADLINES MUST
BE COMMENSURATELY ADJUSTED AND
STILL MUST THE DATE OF THE
TWENTY TWENTY TWO PRIMARY. THE
OTHER BUT THIS WAS REDUCE
LENGTH OF THE AND FOR ELECTIONS
GOAL. IN FORTY SIX THE WHITE
ELECTION. FOR ACTION. HAS BEEN
HELD IN JUNE WITH THE LOAN IF
OF TWO THOUSAND TWO EMERGE
GUBERNATORIAL RESULTS IN AN
UNNECESSARILY ELONGATED
ELECTION CYCLE WITH THE GAP
BETWEEN THE PRIMARY AND THE
GENERAL ELECTION AT EIGHT
MONTHS MOVING THE PRIMARY TO
JUNE WHICH CERTAIN THE ELECTION
SEASON TO A MUCH MORE
REASONABLE FIVE MONTHS. SOME
MIGHT ARGUE THAT HAVING A
PRESIDENTIAL PRIMARY IN MARCH
IN A GUBERNATORIAL PRIMARY IN
JUNE WILL CONFUSE VOTERS THAT
DOESN'T SEEM TO HAVE BEEN THE
CASE IN THE PAST SB NINE
SEVENTY IS SUPPORTED BY COMMON
CAUSE THE LEAGUE OF WOMEN
VOTERS ASIAN AMERICANS
ADVANCING JUST AND HAS NO
OPPOSITION HE WAS APPROVED BY
THE SENATE ON A CONSENT ITEM. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE I WOULD NOW LIKE TO INVITE
NICHOLAS HIDE ONE WITH COMMON
CAUSE INDOOR WROTE WAS WITH THE
LEAGUE OF WOMEN VOTERS. SO BY
OVER THE PHONE LINE. FROM
FORTY. THE PRIMARY SUPPORT
WITNESS GO AHEAD AND PROCEED.
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE FOR
THE LIQUEFIED ON REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIA CALLING CALL ONE OF
THE POTS CAN YOU GET YOUR ME.
YEAH WE ARE YOU. BUT WHAT ABOUT.
BUT AS YOU'RE WEARING OF THE
CHAIRS MENTION COVERED NINETEEN
THAT SIGNIFICANTLY DELAYED THE
ANTICIPATED COMPLETION AND
RELEASE DATE OF THE FEDERAL US
CENSUS DATA WHICH MOST STATES
ICLUDING CALIFORNIA ALLY ON TO
REDISTRICTING. AEROSMITH THE
REDUCING DATA MAY BE DELAYED BY
AS MUCH AS FOUR MONTHS IN
ANTICIPATION OF THE CALIFORNIA
SUPREME COURT OF GRANTED THIS
LEGISLATURE'S EMERGENCY SESSION
EXTEND THE RESISTING DEADLINE
OF DECEMBER FIFTEENTH TWENTY
TWENTY ONE FOR STATE
CORRECTIONAL. HOW FOR MARCH
BLIND. UP FOR MARCH OF THE IS
ACTUALLY AFTER THE QUE THAT
NOMINATION OPENED AND IT. A
LITTLE IMPOSSIBILITY FURTHER
CORGAN PREVENT. EVEN IF CORD
CAN RESTRUCTURE THE NOMINATION
DEADLINE IS NOT IDEAL WITH
DECEMBER REDUCING DEADLINE TO
GET CAN APPLY FROM THREE MONTHS
THE KNOWING DISTRICT POINT THE
PRIMARY ELECTIONS IN MARCH. TO
PUT IT SUCCINCTLY THE EXTENSION
WOULD BE GRANTED ONLY WORKS OF
THE STATE PRIMARIES MOVE FROM
MARCH TO JUNE AS WELL. THE
CHANGE IS NOT ONLY NEEDED FOR
THE STATE ALSO AROUND ONE
HUNDRED COUNTY AND CITIES THE
CONSOLE THEIR LOW. THE STATE.
THREE CAN MOVING FOR THE- FOR
PRESS LIKE TO FIFTY. MAKING CAN
TO COMPETE AND CAL. IN OUR
STATE PROBLEMS. HOWEVER NON
PRESIDENTIAL YEARS WE DO THE
ONGOING BENEFITS DURING THE
PRIMARY BACK TO JIM AS WELL.
PRINCIPALLY SHORTENING THE
CAMPAIGN SEASON WILL MAKE IT
EASIER FOR PEOPLE RUN FOR
OFFICE PRINT COMMON FOLK SONG
GOVERNING. FOR VOTERS TO GET
WELL DESERVED BREAK SELECTION.
ALL THESE REASONS WE STRONGLY
URGE SUPPORT THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON SURE THE FAMILY
MEMBERS CAN I BE HEARD ALSO YES
YES GOOD. OKAY I'M DOOR ROSE
DEPUTY DIRECTOR WITH THE LEGAL
AND VOTERS OF CALIFORNIA THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TESTIFY I'M DELIGHTED TO SEE
WHILE HEALTHY HEART AND HAVE
NOW. BUT THE GOOD SIDE. WE
AGREE WITH THE WHAT MAKES JUST
COME CAUSE COM GIVEN THE FOR
SENSE OF DATA NINE SOME OF
THESE. TO PROVIDE YOU THE TIME
IF NECESSARY FOR REALLY
MEANINGFUL PUBLIC PARTICIPATION
AND REDISTRICTING. IN WALL OF
MY MAKES FOR. THAT HAVE BEEN
EARLIER PRIMARY IN PRESIDENTIAL
YEARS. SHORTER ALEXIAN SEASON
FOR GUBERNATORIAL YEARS CARRIED
CHIRLA BANDAGES- FOR THE
DEMOCRATIC PROCESS. LONGER
CAMPAIGN TO RAISE THE COST OF
AN ELECTION EXACERBATING THE
PROBLEM OF MONEY IN POLITICS.
IF YOU KNOW LIMITS THE FIELD
THE CANDIDATES HIMSELF FINDING
WORK FORCES CANDIDATES TO SPEND
MORE TIME FOR RAISING WHICH WE
ALL KNOW IT IS. NOT A GREAT
THING ONLY NEED FOR MORE
CAMPAIGN CASH INCREASE OF THE
APPOINT THE SPECIAL INTERESTS
OVER THE- INTEREST OF ORDINARY.
VOTERS IN CAMPAIGN MANAGEMENT
HAS TO START EARLIER WHICH
TAKES PRESSURE TIME OKAY THE
FOLKS ON PALM MAKING. EXACTLY
WHAT WITH DO YOU STUDY OUT
THERE FROM THE TWENTY SIXTEEN
ELECTION THAT SHOWED AT LEAST
2% OF AMERICA SAY THEY ARE WORN
OUT BY EXCESSIVELY LONG. CAN AN
EIGHT MONTH BETWEEN THE PRIMARY
AND GENERAL. HUGE SPACE THE
TIME TO MAINTAIN VOTER
ENGAGEMENT IF I BELIEVE
EXPERIENCE WITH THAT IT'S
EASIER TO EDUCATE PEOPLE OF
CANADA IN ABOUT ISSUES. WHEN
THAT TIME FRAME IS MORE. PEOPLE
CAN BE REMEMBER WHO THEY VOTED
FOR THE PRIMARY ELECTION AND
WHY. WE BELIEVE THAT SB NINE
SEVENTIES BOTH NECESSARY FOR
THE PRACTICAL REASONS THAT WERE
STATED AND IT'S ALL OF THE
BENEFITS CALIFORNIA VOTERS. THE
LEAGUE OF WOMEN VOTERS THE
CALIFORNIA- JUST. AND I DON'T
AND WE THANK YOU. OKAY I
BELIEVE THAT'S ALL THE
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT THE MAIN
ONE IS THE MAIN WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT SO- WITH THAT IF
ANYBODY IN SUPPORT IN THE
AUDIENCE WISHING TO STATE THEIR
SOME ANY PERSONS IN THE REMOTE.
LOCATIONS WISHING TO STATE
THEIR SUPPORT. AND THEN I WILL
JUST LET PEOPLE KNOW AGAIN THE
CALL IN NUMBER IS. 877-692-8957
AND THE PAN IS. ONE THREE ONE
FIVE FOUR THREE SEVEN. NOW WITH
THAT AT ANY. ANY MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WANTING TO EXPRESS
SUPPORT. FOR SB NINE SEVENTY ON
THE FUNDS. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WISH TO SHOW SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE THAN THEIR OWN.
AGAIN TO SHOW SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN THEIR OWN NOW.
WE HAVE NO ONE AND THEY KILL.
OKAY THEN WILL MOVE TO I DON'T
THINK WE HAVE ANY OFFICIAL OP.
TO THIS BILL SO THERE'S NO
PRIMARY OPPOSITION WITNESSES
BUT ANYONE. FROM THE PUBLIC
HERE IN ROOM. OPPOSE IN THE
BILL. ANY PERSON THAT REMOTE.
LOCATIONS. AND THEN ANYONE ON
THE PHONE. WISHING TO EXPRESS
OPPOSITION TO SB NINE SEVENTY.
THANK YOU DEAR A CALL PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN THERE- NOW AGAIN
TO A POLE PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO NOW. AND THERE'S NO ONE
AND LIKE YOU. OKAY I WILL BRING
IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE. MY ON
THE PROBLEM WITH THIS IS IT'S
JUST LIKE WILL BRING IT IT
SEEMS LIKE WE'RE JUST PLAN PING
PONG. YOU KNOW I MEAN WE KEEP
MOVING IT TO MARCH AND THEN
BACK TO JUNE I THOUGHT WE HAD
KIND OF MADE A FINAL. POLICY
DECISION WHEN WE PASSED THE
LEGISLATION A FEW YEARS AGO A
COUPLE YEARS AGO. YOU KNOW MY
COLLEAGUE MADE OF. YOU KNOW-
VERY IMPASSIONED SPEECH ON THE
FLOOR- AT AND SEVERAL OF US
AND- AS REPUBLICANS SUPPORTED
THAT MEASURE AS WELL TO MOVE IT
TO- TO MARCH AND JUST KEEP IT
THERE- I GET WITH THE US CENSUS
WHAT THAT POSES THE DELAY- BUT
THAT MIGHT BE AN ARGUMENT FOR
JUST DOING IT FOR THIS ONE
ELECTION- RATHER THAN KIND OF
DOING IT PERMANENTLY WHICH IT
SEEMS LIKE THE- BILL THE- SO.
THAT'S MY CONCERN WITH IT- AND
SO THAT'S WHY I WOULD BE OPPOSE
IN I FEEL LIKE WE'VE ALREADY
DECIDED AS A LEGISLATURE- THAT
WE'RE GONNA HAVE. MARCH
PRIMARIES- FROM NOW ON I DON'T
I DON'T SEE THE ISSUE OF. YOU
KNOW PROLONGED CAMPAIGN- EITHER
A MINISTER IT'S A PROP I
CAMPAIGN IN A GENERAL JUST LIKE
ALWAYS IS WE'RE GONNA HAVE
MARCH- YOU KNOW FROM HERE. YEAH
IT SEEMS LIKE WE JUST CAN'T
KIND OF DO THIS ARE ONCE WHILE
JUST TO BE RELEVANT IN THE
PRESIDENTIAL PRIMARY- I THINK
OF OUR VOTERS OUR CITIZENS WANT
JUST BE CONSISTENT WHAT'S
WHAT'S OUR WINNER PRIMARY IS
GOING TO BE AND WHEN OUR
GENERAL'S GONNA BE. AND AGAIN I
pTHINK WE'VE ALREADY MADE THAT
POLICY DETERMINATION SO I. THAT
THAT'S WHY I WOULD BE- IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS AND LET'S
JUST KEEP IT KEEP IT JUNE MAYBE
DO SOMETHING MORE IT'S JUST FOR
THIS OF THIS KIND UPCOMING
PRIMARY- FOR TWENTY TWENTY. TWO
BECAUSE OF THE CENSUS ISSUE BUT
OTHERWISE KEEP IT IN PLACE- ANY
OTHER. COMMENTS QUESTIONS NOPE
YES MISTER MAYES. WELL YEAH I
DON'T LIKE TO DO THIS PING PONG
EITHER GOING OUT IT JUST IN MY
HOME OPINION I DID NOT AS OF
FILE IN DECEMBER GOING THROUGH
THE HOLIDAY. YOU LET YEAR I
ALSO FOUND FOR US IN THE
LEGISLATURE AT THAT MARCH
DIDN'T WORK OUT I ACTUALLY
PREFER A PREFERRED UNITER STAND
FOR PRESIDENTIAL- POLITICS-
POLITICAL PURPOSES YOU WANT
CALIFORNIANS TO BE RELEVANT
TURNED OUT MAYBE THAT WASN'T AS
WE WEREN'T AS RELEVANT AS WE
THOUGHT THAT WE WERE GOING TO
BE- THIS THIS LAST YEAR- SO I
ACTUALLY DO PREFER JUNE AND I
DON'T LIKE PING PONG BACK AND
FORTH AND FOR THE JUST TO GO
PURPOSES I WOULD HOPE THAT WE
WILL CONTINUE. TO KEEP IN
CANNOT A GOING FORWARD BASIS SO
I'LL ACTUALLY BE SUPPORTING IT-
TODAY. YES MULLIN. IT THEY MISS
CHAIR I INITIALLY HAD
RESERVATIONS WHEN I FOR SAW THE
ABOUT TALK BACK AND FOR THE
SAME CONSIDER. THAT TO MR GALA
HAS OF I AM STRUCK THOUGH THAT.
THE PRIME ELECTION CAL AND-
YEAR I THINK IS DECIDE ON THE
SET. AND WOULD RATHER BUY FOR.
OUR NON PRESIDENTIAL YEAR PRIME
FROM THE PRESIDENTIAL YOUR
PRIMARIES- I'VE COME AROUND ON
THAT ISSUE I THINK THE
GUBERNATORIAL YEARS OUGHT TO BE
STANDARD JUNE I THINK THAT
TIMELINE MAKES SOME SENSE BUT-
I THINK OUR MOST RECENT AT
LEAST IN OUR PARTY- SHOW THAT-
THE INITIAL STATES. MAY WIND
UP- SHIFTING INVOLVING IN
CALIFORNIA MOST CERTAINLY WANTS
TO BE A PART OF THAT EQUATION-
SO I'M GOING TO SUPPORT THE
BILL TODAY TO SAY ENTERED AS A
GIVEN TOIL YEARS IN JAIL BUT I
THINK MY FOR HIS COMMENTS HIS-
HIS THOUGHTS WITH REGARD THIS
MATTER WILL. BE UPON US EDGE
OUR- ABOUT THIS TALK IT BACK
AND FORTH AND PRESS NOW
PRESIDENTIAL YEARS THAT WILL
THE STATE'S A LITTLE MORE GOT
PUBLIC TO THAT WORD OUT TO OUR
BUT ALL BE SUPPORT VIA SUPPORT
BUILDING. THE THANK. FRANK YEAH
FOR BRING THIS FOR I'LL YOU DO
NOT LIKE THEM MARCH THING IT IT
WAS SAME SO A CLUB A I GUESS WE
THOUGHT WE WERE GOING TO BE
WHATEVER WE THOUGHT WE WON'T BE
MORE AND SO IT SEEMS LIKE A
PHYS MORE THAN A ELSE IT ALSO
SEE MAKES CALM. WITH REGARD TO
PAY TIME AND CONFUSED AND
CHRISTMAS AND HOLIDAYS A BEFORE
THE END OF ONE IT'LL AND A JOB
INTO THE WOULD WHICH WILL
HAPPEN AGAIN AND IF WE WILL
COME NO ONE WE DO GOODNESS
THING WILL WILL JUMP RIGHT IN
THE NEXT IT'LL COUPLE MONTHS
WERE HAVING IN THE ALL HELLO WE
HAD TO WITH THE- AND HAVEN'T
ONE MEETING ON THE U. THIS IT
WAS JUST A MESS AND A LOT OF
WHAT AND I'M NOT SURE WHAT IT
WAS WORTH IT IN THE END OF IT
WAS THE EIGHTY CALIFORNIA'S A
LOT. IS GOING HAVE IMPACT
MATTER WHAT WOULD BE NICE TO
GETS CHOSE AND WHO DOES GET JOE
SO AND SO SOME I THINK A I LOOK
AT IN WE DID BEFORE. IT WAS
LIKE. YOU KNOW WHAT IT WAS- SO
I THINK IT'S SOME POINT- I I'M
IN FAVOR OF THE JUNE BECAUSE I
THINK IT JUST SOME UNDER THE
IT. FITS MORE INTO WHAT WE'RE
DOING AND IN CALIFORNIA THAN
ANYTHING ELSE- AND- IT JUST
SEEMS SO RIGHT NOW THIS SEEMS A
LONG TIME FOR MARCH TO. OVER
ALONG TIME. AND I WILL SAVE
THAT WE HAVE PAY THEM TO CREATE
SOME X. FORCE BUT I WILL SAY
THAT BECAUSE HEAD THAT MAYBE.
WOKE UP WHEN THAT ME AND THE
BOREDOM OF. OF THIS LONG CYCLE.
BUT BUT I THINK IT'S A POINT I
YOU KNOW I'M I'M HOPING THAT
PEOPLE WILL CURE IT WITH
ENOUGH. REMAIN EVERYBODY WITH.
PEOPLE SHOULD PLUS. OF YOU. HOW
DO WOULD MAKE SENSE IN
CALIFORNIA MUCH MORE THAN
ANYTHING ELSE BUT THAT. I'LL BE
THE THIS SOME BECAUSE THAT LIKE
THE- PRIOR. JUNE AND- MAKES LOT
MORE SENSE TO ME CAL. THAT IT
DOES IT IS ELSE OF THIS. THE
WINGS HELLO. I LIKE AND I. WAS
BEING FOR THE BIG. BOOM AND IT
DIDN'T. IT WAS A FIZZLE MORE
THAN ANYTHING ELSE SOUGHT THE-
OUT OF IT WAS WORTH IT OR NOT
ALL THE- DRAMA WITH. FILING
EARLY IN DECEMBER AND THIS AND
THAT IN A ROW. ALL DAY AND- NOT
WITH LARGE WITH WHATEVER GET
OUT KIND OF THING SO. ANYWAY
BUT WANT TO THANK YOU FOR LEASE
BRING IT TO US THE IT BUT I
HOPE EXAMPLE WE CISCO OF STABLE.
IT AND STOP BACK AND FORTH.
PEOPLE WITHOUT CONFUSING THEM.
I'M OF THE BILL. THEY GET IN
MOVED AND SECONDED RIGHT HOW
ARE EVER HAD BEEN YEAH OKAY
YEAH MOVED. DOCTOR WEBER AND
SECOND BY MISSED CALL. I MISSED
MAZES ARE A AN WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE MISTER CHAIRMAN SIR
OKAY- BACK TO A CLEAN UP
SENATOR LARS BILLS. MISTER COOK
WOULD YOU PLEASE CALL THE CALL
THE ROLL. THE MOTION IS DO PATH
AND RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS BERMAN HI
BERMAN HI GALLAGHER NO
GALLAGHER NO CALDERON. CALDERON
HI LOW LOW HI MAYES MAY IF I
MULLIN MULLIN ARE A WEBER.
WEBER HI. SIX TO ONE IN THE
BILL IS OUT AND- MISTER
CHAIRMAN I WILL RETURN THE
PROVERBIAL GAVEL BACK TO YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER VICE CHAIR-
AND I HAVE NO IDEA. WHERE I AM-
MULLIN MULLIN AND MORE ON. THE
STERN HE SAID LET'S MOVE ON TO
THE LAST ITEM OF THE AGENDA
ITEM NUMBER FIVE SB SEVEN
THIRTY NINE. WITH THE SUMMER
MULLIN PRESENTING ON CENTER
STERN BEHALF FOR MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WERE INTERESTED IN
SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF OR IN
OPPOSITION TO SB SEVEN THIRTY
NINE PLEASE CALL IN NOW THAT'S
ON NUMBER MULLIN THANK YOU FOR
PRESENTING ON BEHALF OF SENATOR
STERN YOU MAY PROCEED. THEY
GIVE US CHAIR NOVEMBER TWENTY
TWENTY ALL REGISTER
CALIFORNIANS WILL RECEIVE A
VOTE BY MAIL BALLOT. FOR SOME
VOTERS THIS WILL BE RETAINED
BUT FOR OTHERS THIS WILL BE THE
FIRST TIME THEY HAVE CAST THEIR
BALLOTS FROM THE SAFETY OF
THEIR HOME. IN AN AGE OF
INFORMATION WE NEED TO ENSURE
THAT ALL CALIFORNIANS ARE
RECEIVING ONLY THE MOST REAL
RELIABLE AND CORRECT
INFORMATION ABOUT THEIR- RIGHT
TO APPLY FOR RECEIVE OR RETURN
A VOTE BY MAIL BALLOT.
CURRENTLY IT IS A MISDEMEANOR
FOR PERSON TO DISTRIBUTE
INFORMATION WITH AN INTENT TO
DECEIVE VOTERS ABOUT THE
LOCATION OF POLLING PLACES.
ABOUT THE QUALIFICATIONS TO
REGISTER TO VOTE IN THE
QUALIFICATIONS TO VOTE. HOWEVER
THE LAW IS SILENT WHEN IT COMES
TO DELIBERATE MISINFORMATION
DISTRIBUTION REGARDING A VOTE
BY MAIL QUALIFICATIONS. THAT'S
WHY SB SEVEN THIRTY NINE ADDS
ADDITIONAL SAFEGUARDS TO VOTE
BY MAIL MIS INFORMATION.
FARMING CALIFORNIANS WITH
CORRECT INFORMATION ABOUT
VOTING BY MAIL IS IMPORTANT
BOTH. FOR THE INTEGRITY OF OUR
ELECTION AND THE CONFIDENCE OF
OUR VOTERS. IN LATE APRIL THE
PEW RESEARCH CENTER FOUND THAT
TWO THIRDS OF AMERICANS BELIEVE
THAT IT IS VERY LIKELY OR
SOMEWHAT LIKELY. THAT THE
CORONAVIRUS OUTBREAK WILL
SIGNIFICANTLY DISRUPT PEOPLE'S
ABILITY TO VOTE IN THE
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION. THIS
ONLY FURTHER UNDERLINES HOW
IMPORTANT IT IS TO RESTORE
VOTER CONFIDENCE IN OUR
ELECTION. VOTERS WHO DON'T VOTE
BY MAIL MAY NOT KNOW FOR
EXAMPLE. THAT THEY CAN RETURN
THEIR BALLOTS TO ANY POLLING
LOCATION OR COUNTY ELECTIONS
DROP OFF BOX THEY CAN RETURN
THEIR BALLOT EVEN IF IT IS
POSTMARKED ON ELECTION DAY. AND
THEY CAN CHECK THE STATUS OF
THEIR BALLOT THROUGHOUT THE
PROCESS. WITH THEIR COUNTY.
KNOWLEDGE IS POWER AND SB SEVEN
THIRTY NINE IS A COMMON SENSE
MEASURES TAKEN TO EMPOWER
PROTECT VOTERS AS THEY FULFILL
CITIZENS. MOST SACRED
OBLIGATION. LASTLY I WOULD LIKE
TO TAKE AS AUTHOR AMENDMENTS
THE URGENCY CLAUSE. APPROVED BY
THE RULES COMMITTEE EARLIER
TODAY. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MULLIN. NOW LET'S MOVE
ON TO THE PRIMARY WITNESS TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
THE PRIMARY WITNESS IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL IS TIFFANY MOCK
FROM THE OFFICE. OF SECRETARY
OF STATE OUT EXPEDIA WHO IS ON
THE PHONE MS MOCK THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. THANK YOU. RENT AND-
THANK YOU MEMBER FOR YOUR WORK
ON IT MEASURE WE ARE PLEASED
SUPPORT SB SEVEN THIRTY NINE
WHICH WILL IMPROVE THE
INTEGRITY OF ELECTIONS BY
COMBATING THIS INFORMATION
SPECIFIC TO VOTING BY NOW. THE
BILL MERELY INJURES CRIMINAL
PENALTIES FOR DISTRIBUTING
FALSE INFORMATION REGARDING THE
QUALIFICATIONS APPLY FOR
RECEIVE A RETURN ABOUT BY MAIL
BACK. FOR THOSE REASONS WE URGE
YOUR- AYE VOTE TODAY AND ONCE
YOUR PLATE THE SUPPORT SB SEVEN
THIRTY NINE. THANK YOU MS MARK
ARE THERE ADDITIONAL ARE THERE
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN THIRTY NINE
WERE HERE THE COMMITTEE HEARING
OR ROOM. SEEING NONE AS A
REMINDER ADDITIONAL IN THIS IS
SHOULD SIMPLY STATE- AWAY
WHATEVER WE'RE GOOD- NET AND
LET'S NOW GO TO OUR REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATIONS OTHER ANY
WITNESSES THAT ONE OF THE
REMOTE HAS MANY STATIONS TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN
THIRTY NINE NO THERE ARE NOT
THE PHONE LINES ARE NOW OPEN
FOR ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN THIRTY NINE
MODERATOR DO WE HAVE ANYBODY ON
THE LINE WHO WISHES TO SPEAK.
IN SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN THIRTY
NINE. IN A FEEL LIKE TO SHOW
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE AT THE
END THERE- NOW AGAIN TO SHOW
SUPPORT. PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEY'RE ALL NOW. NOW THINK WE
HAVE Q. AND THE Q. LOCAL CO
LINE TWENTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
AFTERNOON MOLECULAR MERRILL
AGAIN WITH A CALIFORNIA WE GET
CONSERVATION BETTER AND BUT
PART OF THAT SEVEN THIRTY NINE.
THANK YOU. ENACT THE LAW TO
LINE THIRTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI THIS IS THE CURRENT L<c.cyan>G</c>
FROM THE CALIFORNIA CLEAN MONEY
CAMPAIGN AND STRONG SUPPORT
DESK P. SEVEN THIRTY NINE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. AT AS A
REMINDER TO SHOW SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS THE ONE THAN THEIR OWN
NOW ONE THEN ZERO BIRTH THE
PORT. WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE AND
LIKE HE'LL. GREAT NOW LET'S GO
TO ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION-
I DO NOT BELIEVE THERE IS ANY
MAIN OPPOSITION AND THERE IS
NOT IS THERE ANY OPPOSITION
TESTIMONY IN THE HEARING ROOM
TODAY THERE IS NOT- IS THERE
ANY OPPOSITION TESTIMONY AT ANY
OF THE REMOTE STATIONS THERE IS
NOT- NOT A MODERATOR IS THERE
ANY OPPOSITION ON THE PHONE
LINES. IF YOU WISH TO OPPOSE
PLEASE PRESS ONE AT THE END
THERE NOW AGAIN IF YOUR POLLS
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN THERE NOW.
WE HAVE NO ONE AND THE KIA.
GREAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
TURNING IT OVER TO COLLEAGUES
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
MISTER VICE CHAIR YEAH- I'M
SUPPORT OF THE BILL- YOU KNOW
BUT I DO WANT POTENTIAL ISSUE
HERE IN AND- I THINK IT'S TAKEN
CARE OF BY THE INTENT LANGUAGE
HERE THAT THE YOU WOULD HAVE TO
BE INTENDED. BUT BACK TO MY
THEME I THINK IN THIS HEARING
AS IT I THINK THERE IS GOING TO
BE SOME CONFUSION AND SO WHAT
IF SOMEBODY IS SAYING HEY YOU
YOU HAVE. TEN DAYS YOU KNOW TO
GO TO A VOTE CENTER TO GET
ASSISTANCE AND IN FACT YOU
REALLY DON'T YOU ONLY HAVE
THREE DAYS BECAUSE THIS THAT
PARTICULAR COUNTY. YOU KNOW HAS
OPTED TO JUST GO THREE DAYS
BEFORE THE ELECTION- I MEAN YOU
COULD SEE THAT THERE COULD BE
STATEMENTS THAT ARE MADE.
BECAUSE OF THE CONFUSION OF
THIS AND THAT'S REALLY AND
AGAIN MY POINT AS WELL SHE
TRYING KEEP THINGS THE STATUS
QUO AND KEEP. ACCESS THE STATUS
QUO AS POSSIBLE- I DO HAVE SOME.
SOME CONCERNS ABOUT THAT
OBVIOUSLY I THINK WE ALL WE CAN
ALL AGREE THAT WE DON'T WANT.
INTENTIONAL MISSTATEMENTS BEING
MADE OUT THERE AND YOU KNOW
THIS WOULD HELP PROTECT AGAINST
THAT. ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS FROM COLLEAGUES- DO
WE HAVE A MOTION OUR SECOND. I
HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND. THE
SUMMER MULLIN WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE JUST A THANK YOU TO MY
COLLEAGUE MISTER GALLAGHER-
INTENT TO DECEIVE IS THE KEY
PHRASE- HERE AND I WANT TO
THANK THE CHAIR- FOR ENSURING
THAT OUR OUR ELECTION THIS
NOVEMBER IS A VOTE BY MAIL
AFFAIR. AND WE NEED TO BE
UPDATED ALL OF OUR STATUTES TO
REFLECT THAT- NEW REALITY AND I
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH A SLIMMER MULLIN-
THIS BILL MAKES A MINOR
CLARIFICATION TO A. B. SIXTEEN
SEVENTY EIGHT A BILL THAT I
AUTHORED TWO YEARS AGO IN AN
EFFORT TO CRACK DOWN ON
ELECTION MISINFORMATION I
RECOMMEND SUPPORT- MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL. THE VOTE.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO ADD AN URGENCY CLAWS
AND RE REFER TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
BERMAN HI BERMAN HI GALLAGHER
HI GALLAGHER HI CALDERON.
CALDERON HI LO. LO HI MAYES.
MAYES AYE MULLIN. MULLIN AYE
WEBER. WEBER HI. SEVEN ZERO THE
BILL IS OUT ON A SEVEN ZERO
VOTE- AND NOW- THAT CONCLUDES
THE ITEMS ON THE COMMITTEE'S
AGENDA FOR TODAY- BUT WANT TO
OPEN UP THE ROLE FOR MEMBERS
WHO MIGHT OF MISSED A VOTER TO
EARLIER. YEAH YEAH YEAH YEAH
PLEASE MISTER SECRETARY. CALL
THE ROLL FOR. ANY OF VARIOUS
THE ABSENT MEMBERS ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR THE CURRENT
VOTED SIX TO ZERO CALDERON
CALDERON HI THAT SEVEN TO ZERO.
THAT IT THESE STONES ARE. THAT
IS THAT RIGHT THAT IS IT THE
HEARING IS ADJOURNED THANK
EVERYBODY.